what should in an Ideal World Define
someone as a writer it isn't that they
publish books or give talks at literary
festivals or wear black it's that they
belong to a distinct group of people who
whenever they are confused or in
distress gain the greatest possible
relief from jotting things down writers
in the true sense are those who scribble
as opposed to drink exercise or chat
their way out of pain
the act of writing especially in a
journal or diary is filled with
therapeutic benefits so deeply do
certain ideas threaten the status quo
even if they ultimately offer us
benefits the mind will ruthlessly forget
them in the name of a quiet life but our
Diaries are a forum in which we can
raise and then Galvanize ourselves into
answering the large questions which lie
behind the stewardship of Our Lives what
do I really want should I leave what do
I feel for them
we may not quite know what we want to
say until we've started to write writing
begets more writing the first sentence
makes the second one clearer after a
short paragraph that was summoned from
apparent air we start to know where this
might be going we learn what we think in
the process of being forced to utter
ideas outside of our swampy Minds the
page becomes a guardian of our authentic
elusive self
here we can make vowels and attempt to
stick to them no more humiliation the
end of masochism ordinary life can seem
to have no place for stock taking and
moments of grand inquiry but the page
demands and rewards them what am I
trying to do who am I what is Meaningful
for me we'd never get away with such
things at the dinner table even among
people who claim to love us but here
they make sense
we can look back at what we've written
and understand the page is a supreme
arena for processing it can drain pain
of its rawness we can get used to
disasters and stabilize Joys we can turn
Panic into lists five ways to survive
this
six things I am going to tell them four
reasons not to despair we won't need to
be so jittery in the world outside after
we have told the notebook all this
the page becomes a laboratory in which
to try out what might shock and surprise
we don't need to honor everything we say
we're giving it a go and seeing how we
feel it's the first draft of a letter to
ourselves
looking back at what we have written
should be embarrassing if what we mean
by that is hyperbolic disjointed
uncertain and wild if we aren't appalled
by much of what we have said to
ourselves we aren't beginning to be
truthful
and therefore won't learn
if in ordinary life we make a little
more sense than we might if we are a bit
calmer than we were it's perhaps because
somewhere in a draw there are pages of
tightly compressed handwriting that have
helped us to understand our pain safely
explore our fantasies and guide us to a
more bearable future
we can educate ourselves in the art of
being calm not through Specialties or
slow breathing but through thinking this
book guides us through that process